>> Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
>> Yoko: THE WINNER IS...
>> Tyra: IN TOKYO, YAYA WON
HER FIFTH CHALLENGE IN A ROW.
>> Norelle: LIKE,
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> Ann: I THOUGHT
I KNEW WHO YOU WERE.
I DON'T KNOW
IF I LIKE WHAT I SEE NOW.
>> Tyra: WHILE ANN LOST
HER LOVE FOR EVA...
>> Ann: HONESTLY,
I WANT EVA TO BE ELIMINATED.
>> Tyra: BUT IN THE END,
IT WAS NORELLE WHO FAILED
TO STEP UP...
>> Janice: PHOTOGRAPH--FABULOUS.
WALK--HORRIBLE.
>> Tyra: AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
FOUR GIRLS REMAIN--
AMANDA, ANN, EVA AND YAYA.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
>> Ann: IT'S NOT ME
TO PUT ON A PAIR OF PUMPS
AND, LIKE, HEELS EVERY DAY.
IT'S TO PUT ON A PAIR
OF SWEATPANTS AND A BANDANA.
I DON'T WEAR MAKEUP
UNLESS I GO TO THE BAR.
>> Eva: I DON'T WEAR MAKEUP
EITHER. I DON'T WEAR MAKEUP.
>> Ann: YEAH, YOU DO, AND YOU
KNOW DAMN WELL
YOU PUT IT ON EVERY DAY.
>> Eva: HERE. I HAVE NO CHOICE
BUT TO HERE.
>> Ann: WHY?
>> Eva: ANN AND I WERE CLOSE
COMING INTO THIS...
(screams)
>> Eva: BUT AS TIME PROGRESSED,
WE STARTED DRIFTING APART.
>> Ann: IT HURT ME
AND IT HURT NORELLE THAT YOU
SAID THAT YOU HOPED SHE DID BAD.
>> Eva: YOU SAID SOME... TOO,
SO DON'T EVEN.
>> Ann: I KNOW WE'RE NOT GONNA
NOT BE FRIENDS, BUT I THINK
SINCE THE WHOLE
NORELLE SITUATION
IT WILL NEVER BE THE SAME.
>> Eva: (sighs)
>> Amanda: TYRA MAIL!
"DO FASHION DESIGNERS
INSPIRE STREET STYLE,
OR DOES STREET STYLE
INSPIRE FASHION DESIGNERS?"
>> Yaya: GO, STREET STYLE!
GO, STREET STYLE!
THE TYRA MAIL TELLS US
TO PREPARE TO SEE
SOME JAPANESE STREET FASHION.
>> Sawa: WELCOME, LADIES.
>> All: THANK YOU.
>> Sawa: I'M GOING
TO TEACH YOU TODAY
ALL ABOUT TOKYO STREET FASHION.
>> Amanda: WE SAW SAWA WEARING
HER LITTLE MR. POTATO HEAD HAT.
I MEAN, BUT SHE ROCKED IT.
THAT WAS SO CUTE.
>> Sawa: I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOME
REAL TOKYO STREET FASHION
EXAMPLE.
>> Ann: WHEN I FIRST SAW HER,
I WAS KIND OF LIKE, "OKAY, WHERE
WAS YOUR MIRROR THIS MORNING?"
>> Sawa: LOOK AT HER.
AMAZING, ISN'T SHE?
SEE, LAYER GOING ON,
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
HER KNEE SOCKS HAS A LITTLE
FRILLED EDGE,
THAT MAKES MORE LIKE
A LOLITA LOOK.
THIS BELT JUST BY ITSELF
IS ALREADY AMAZING ACCESSORY.
>> Yaya: I WAS LIKE,
"WOW, THIS IS NOT A JOKE.
THEY'RE SERIOUS."
LIKE THAT'S REALLY
YOUR EVERYDAY GETUP.
>> Sawa: YOU DON'T HAVE TO COPY
THE STYLES COMPLETELY.
IT'S JUST AN IDEA, YOU KNOW,
TO CREATE THE TOP MODEL STYLE.
I BROUGHT SOME CLOTHES
SO YOU CAN CREATE
SOME TOKYO STREET STYLE.
>> Eva: WE HAD TO GO AND GET
CLOTHES FROM THE RACK AND
INCORPORATE
OR DO WHAT WE THINK
IS TOKYO STREET FASHION.
>> Yaya: OOH, SORRY.
>> Eva: IS THIS SMALL?
>> Ann: THAT'D BE
WAY, WAY, WAY TOO SHORT ON ME.
LIKE, I'M 5 FOOT, 11.
NONE OF THESE CLOTHES
AREN'T GONNA FIT.
HOW MANY TOPS--YOU TOOK THREE.
GEE, THERE'S, LIKE,
NOTHING OUT THERE.
>> Eva: YEAH.
>> Ann: THERE REALLY ISN'T.
DO YOU NEED THEM ALL?
>> Eva: AMANDA TAKE
EIGHT SHIRTS.
ANN PISSED OFF AT AMANDA.
>> Amanda: WHICH ONE
DO YOU LIKE?
>> Ann: I DON'T KNOW, BECAUSE
THERE'S...
>> Amanda: I'M LIKE, "DO YOU
WANT THIS SHIRT?"
TAKE IT OFF, GIVE IT TO HER.
SHE TRIES IT ON, SAYS NO.
I WAS GIVING HER THE SHIRTS
OFF MY BACK WHEN, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE IN A COMPETITION.
>> Eva: TRY THIS SHIRT ON.
JUST TRY IT ON, HONEY.
>> Ann: YES, IT DOES.
>> Eva: NO, IT DOESN'T.
>> Ann: YOU GUYS ARE JUST
SAYING THAT BECAUSE YOU WANT
TO GO OUT THERE.
>> Eva: FIRST OF ALL,
I'M TRYIN' TO HELP YOU.
SO LET'S GET SERIOUS RIGHT NOW.
>> Ann: THEY DIDN'T GIVE US
A TIME LIMIT, DID THEY?
>> Eva: NO.
>> Sawa: HEY, GIRLS,
ARE YOU READY?
>> Amanda: ALMOST.
>> Yaya: I'VE BEEN READY FOR A
LONG TIME.
I'M JUST WAITING.
>> Sawa: OOH-LA-LA.
CUTE.
HMM, OKAY.
YOU LOOK AMAZING.
YOU COORDINATED REALLY WELL
USING THE DIFFERENT PATTERNS,
COLORS.
GREAT.
THE STYLE IS REALLY GOOD,
BUT, HMM,
MAYBE YOU NEED LIKE, YOU KNOW,
GIANT JEWELRY MAYBE.
OOH, SCHOOLGIRL.
YEAH, YOU NEED A LITTLE BIT
MORE, I DON'T KNOW,
MAYBE LIGHT COLOR COORDINATION
IN A DIFFERENT COLOR.
ANN...
NEEDS A LITTLE ACCESSORIES.
YOU COULD ADD
A LITTLE BIT MORE COLOR.
THAT MAKES YOU MUCH BETTER
PROBABLY.
>> Eva: YOU CAN TELL ANN WAS
UNCOMFORTABLE.
SHE STOOD THERE WITH HER ARMS
CROSSED THE WHOLE TIME.
SHE WAS JUST PISSED.
>> Sawa: YOUR CHALLENGE TODAY
IS COORDINATING
A TOKYO STREET STYLE
THAT WILL INSPIRE
THE JAPANESE DESIGNER MILK.
AND THE THEME
OF THE MILK'S NEXT COLLECTION
IS BABY DOLL LOLITA.
AND YOU WILL HAVE
JUST A T-MOBILE SIDEKICK,
WHICH CAN LOCATE
FOUR DIFFERENT STORES.
YOU CAN ONLY SHOP THERE.
>> Eva: SO TODAY'S CHALLENGE IS
TO HIT THE STREETS OF TOKYO
WITH 20,000 YEN,
GET YOUR CLOTHES
AND BE AT THIS DESIGNER BY 6:00.
>> Sawa: IF YOU GET LATE THERE,
YOU'RE GONNA LOSE
THIS CHALLENGE.
SO DON'T BE LATE THERE.
THE ONE WHO DO THE BEST
YOU WILL MEET
A VERY, VERY IMPORTANT PERSON
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY.
>> Eva: WHO?
>> Sawa: I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT.
>> Eva: I'M DROPPED OFF
IN THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE
WITH MY MAP, MY SIDEKICK.
AND I'M BY MYSELF
TRYING TO GET TO MILK BY 6:00
WITH A FULL-ON OUTFIT.
I'M SO CONFUSED.
>> Amanda: WHERE'S
THE OKAY BUTTON?
>> Amanda: I'M LEGALLY BLIND,
AND SO I COULDN'T SEE
THE STREET SIGNS.
AND WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR SOMETHING,
VISION'S IMPORTANT.
THIS IS FUNNY.
THIS IS SO... FUNNY.
I DON'T EVEN... KNOW
WHAT STREET I'M ON.
I AM VERY WORRIED
ABOUT NAVIGATING TOKYO,
BUT I THOUGHT AS LONG
AS I FIND ONE STORE,
HOWEVER MANY HOURS I HAD,
THAT I'LL BE OKAY.
I'LL BE OKAY.
HOW DO I GET UP THERE?
>> Amanda: WHO'S THE WOMAN?
OH, YEAH!
IS THAT THE FINAL PRICE,
THE 10,000 YEN?
OKAY.
METAMORPHOSE
IS A REALLY COOL STORE
AND EVERYTHING WAS BABY DOLL.
YAY!
>> Amanda: NO, I'VE GOT TIME.
I DIDN'T WANT TO GET LOST
LOOKING FOR ANOTHER STORE
AND NOT BE ABLE
TO FIND MY WAY TO MILK
AND BE LATE AND DISQUALIFIED,
SO I FIGURED I'M FINISHED.
>> Yaya: OKAY,
IT'S ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Yaya: THE FIRST PLACE
I GO TO, I THINK,
WAS MARTHA'S CLOSET.
>> Yaya: 20,000 YEN REALLY
DOESN'T GO A LONG WAY HERE.
>> Ann: IT'S LIKE THERE'S
ALL THESE AMAZING CLOTHES,
BUT, LIKE, IT'S KIND OF
LIKE THAT WHOLE
THIS IS DOOR NUMBER ONE.
DO YOU WANT TO KEEP THIS,
OR DO YOU WANT TO GIVE IT UP
AND TAKE DOOR NUMBER TWO?
LIKE, THERE'S THREE
OTHER STORES THAT I STILL
HAVE NOT BEEN TO.
SO I BOUGHT CAPRI/SKIRT THING
FOR LIKE $40.
>> Woman: (speaking Japanese)
>> Eva: OH, HERE WE GO AGAIN.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY?
IT'S NOT ENGLISH.
IT MAKES NO SENSE IN THE WORLD.
I AM SO CONFUSED.
STREETS LOOK DIFFERENT.
LIKE, A LOT OF THE CHARACTERS
ARE WRITTEN IN JAPANESE.
>> Man: WHERE DO YOU WANT TO GO?
>> Ann: I WAS SO LOST.
SO FINALLY,
I STARTED ASKING PEOPLE.
ARIGATO.
>> Eva: EXCUSE ME.
DO YOU SPEAK ENGLISH?
OH, GOD, THANK YOU.
>> Man: AND THEN THE NEXT STREET
ALONG PARALLEL TO THIS
IS CALLED CAT STREET.
>> Eva: OKAY.
>> Man: OKAY?
>> Eva: I'M GONNA TRY
TO FIND IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
>> Eva: BANANA!
>> Ann: WHERE
IS THAT DAMN STORE?
DID YOU GO TO METAMORPHOSE?
>> Eva: THAT'S
WHAT I'M LOOKIN' FOR.
METAMORPHOSE IS THIS WAY.
>> Ann: THIS WAY?
>> Eva: THIS WAY.
>> Ann: EVA, NO IT'S NOT.
>> Eva: ANN,
I HAVE TO TALK TO YOU.
>> Ann: EVA, I HAVE ONE THING.
>> Eva: ANN,
I HAVE TO TALK TO YOU.
>> Ann: YOU KEEP THE MAP OUT.
I'LL KEEP THE THING OUT.
BEFORE THIS CHALLENGE,
EVA AND I HAVE KIND OF BEEN,
NOT AT EACH OTHERS THROATS,
BUT JUST SEPARATE.
AND THEN IT WAS KIND OF WEIRD,
BECAUSE WHEN WE SAW EACH OTHER,
IT'S KIND OF LIKE THAT WAS ALL
THROWN OUT THE WINDOW
BECAUSE WE BOTH NEEDED HELP,
AND WE WERE JUST LIKE, "AH!"
>> Eva: WHERE IS--
AMERICANS!
HE LOOKS AMERICAN.
LOOK IT, HE'S GOT GLASSES.
DO YOU SPEAK ENGLISH?
YOU'RE SCARING
THESE PEOPLE AWAY.
>> Amanda: I THINK MY STRATEGY
OF STICKING TO ONE STORE
IS LESS STRESSFUL.
I WASN'T TRAIPSING AROUND TOKYO
IN THE RAIN
GETTIN' ALL HOT AND SWEATY.
>> Ann: DO YOU KNOW
WHERE METAMORPHOSE IS?
METAMOR--META--WHAT IS IT?
>> Eva: METAMORPHOSE.
>> Ann: METAMORPHOSE
IS A HALF-BLOCK BEYOND MILK,
SO WE NEED TO GO THIS WAY.
SECOND-FLOOR WINDOW.
>> Eva: THIS IS 628 RIGHT HERE.
628.
>> Ann: METAMORPHOSE.
>> Eva: YOU'RE RIGHT HERE.
THIS IS THE SAD CAFé.
>> Ann: THAT'S WHAT IS SAYS?
>> Eva: NO, I'M--
ENGLISH PEOPLE.
>> Ann: JUST GET DRENCHED
IN THE RAIN.
>> Eva: METAMORPHOSE!
>> Ann: FINALLY GET TO
METAMORPHOSE, AND I'M LIKE,
"THIS IS WHAT I, LIKE, RAN FOR?"
I SHOULD HAVE BOUGHT
THAT OTHER SHIRT.
>> Eva: I SHOULD OF BOUGHT
THOSE TIGHTS.
>> Ann: OH, LIKE, I'M MAD.
>> Eva: BUT I CAN TAKE YOU
TO EXACTLY WHERE
THAT OTHER STORE IS.
I KNOW EXACTLY WHERE IT IS.
>> Ann: NO, EVA, THERE'S NO WAY.
>> Eva: OKAY, WE NEED
TO GET STUFF FROM HERE
AND THEN GO TO THE MILK.
>> Ann: I JUST HAD TO BUY
WHATEVER WAS THERE
AND MAKE IT WORK.
6394?
>> Eva: 6393.
>> Ann: OH, WAIT, I DID SEE IT.
IT'S THIS WAY.
GO THIS WAY.
JUST GO IN HERE.
EVA, RIGHT HERE IS MILK.
>> Eva: HERE.
>> Ann: TO THE SECOND FLOOR.
>> Yaya: AT THIS POINT,
I'M FINISHED BUT STILL HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME.
AND I JUST REALLY WANTED
A KIMONO.
SO I WENT AND GOT A KIMONO,
WHICH I'M VERY PROUD OF.
WHAT I'M NOT PROUD OF
IS THE FACT THAT--
THAT I HAVE TEN MINUTES
AND I HAVE TO GET DRESSED.
I GO INTO A RESTAURANT
TO GET DRESSED.
AND THERE IS TWO MINUTES
UNTIL 6:00.
>> Eva: NOT NECESSARILY.
>> Amanda: IT'S HARD TO TELL.
>> Amanda: SHE'S NOT.
>> Ann: NOT GOOD.
>> Amanda: I HOPE SHE'S, LIKE,
NOT JUST STANDING OUT IN FRONT
OF THE STORE FACE, YOU KNOW?
>> Yaya: OKAY,
THAT STORE WAS CLOSED,
BUT WHERE'S THE PRESSROOM?
>> Yaya: MAYBE IT'S NOT HERE.
OH, MY GOODNESS,
LOOK AT THE MAP.
>> Amanda: UH-OH.
IT HAS TO BE PAST 6:00 NOW.
WHEN WE HEAR THE BELLS CHIME
6:00,
AND YAYA IS NOWHERE TO BE SEEN.
>> Woman: HELLO.
>> Man: HI, WELCOME TO MILK.
IT'S NOW 6:00,
AND I WAS EXPECTING FOUR GIRLS,
BUT I ONLY SEE THREE, OKAY?
>> Yaya: I'M RUNNING AROUND
FRANTIC, AND I'M NOT SEEING THE
PRESSROOM.
I SENSED ALREADY, BY THE TIME
I'M CROSSING THE STREET, THAT
I'M LATE.
AND EVEN IF IT'S ONE MINUTE
LATE, I'M STILL LATE.
>> Shingo: SO THIS IS HITOMI.
SHE IS THE DIRECTOR FOR MILK AND
MILK BOY.
AND I'M SHINGO. AND I DO THE
MEN'S LINE.
I WILL SEE YOU GUYS ONE BY ONE.
>> Eva: I WALK OUTSIDE,
AND WHO'S THERE BUT YAYA.
>> Hitomi: TOO LATE.
>> Shingo: YOU'RE VERY LATE.
>> Yaya: I'M REALLY, REALLY
SORRY FOR COMING LATE.
>> Shingo: OKAY.
>> Hitomi: OKAY.
>> Shingo: BYE.
I'M SORRY, WE CAN'T.
THANKS FOR COMING IN.
SEE YOU AROUND.
UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Hitomi: MM-HMM.
>> Yaya: THEY VERY POLITELY TOLD
ME TO LEAVE BECAUSE I WAS LATE.
TWO MINUTES LATE
WAS TWO MINUTES LATE.
SO I'M GOING BACK HOME.
>> Amanda: YAYA'S WON,
LIKE, FIVE TIMES.
BUT SHE AIN'T WINNIN' THIS ONE.
IT'S SOMEBODY ELSE'S TURN.
>> Hitomi: OKAY, KEEP WALKING
THIS BACK.
OH, NICE.
HOW OLD ARE YOU?
>> Amanda: 25.
>> Shingo: TOO OLD?
>> Hitomi: TOO OLD.
>> Shingo: TELL US
ABOUT YOUR LOOK.
>> Ann: MY LOOK TODAY?
>> Shingo: MM-HMM.
>> Ann: I DON'T KNOW. I JUST
LIKED IT 'CAUSE IT WAS ORIGINAL.
THEY HAD ME DESCRIBE,
LIKE, WHAT INSPIRED MY OUTFIT.
AND IT WAS REALLY HARD TO
DESCRIBE IT.
IT WASN'T LIKE JUST A SKIRT OR
PANTS.
IT WAS KIND OF LIKE IN BETWEEN.
>> Hitomi: OKAY. THANK YOU
COMING.
>> Ann: AND THAT WAS IT.
>> Hitomi: HOW OLD ARE YOU?
>> Eva: 19.
>> Hitomi: 19, PERFECT.
>> Shingo: YOU'RE 19?
>> Eva: 19, YEAH.
I'M THE YOUNGEST ONE, I KNOW.
>> Hitomi: YEAH.
>> Eva: I WANTED TO PUT
A LITTLE JAPANESE STREET FASHION
WITH THE POLKA DOTS TO THE SIDE
AND THE SHIRT SAYS,
"DON'T BLAME ME."
AFTER THE GO-SEE,
WE'RE CALLED BACK IN.
>> Hitomi: SO, AMANDA...
>> Shingo: LOOKS BETTER.
>> Hitomi: YEAH, YEAH.
AND, ANN--
>> Shingo: SHE THINKS
IT WAS PRETTY HARD FOR YOU
TO FIND A SIZE, YEAH.
I THINK YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
>> Hitomi: OKAY, EVA.
>> Shingo: YOU HAVE
GOOD CHARACTERISTICS.
SHE THINKS IT'S OVERALL GOOD.
SO SHE WAS REALLY INSPIRED
THE MOST FROM EVA.
>> Ann: YAY!
>> Amanda: YAY!
>> Eva: MY IDEA WAS FIND THINGS
THAT DON'T GO TOGETHER THAT LOOK
REALLY STUPID AND YOU'LL WIN.
HOW DUMB DO I LOOK?
>> Shingo: AND, EVA, TOMORROW
YOU WILL MEET A VERY IMPORTANT
PERSON IN THE JAPANESE INDUSTRY,
AND YOU'RE GONNA JOIN HIM
FOR BREAKFAST TOMORROW.
YOU CAN FIND SOMEONE TO SHARE
YOUR PRIZE IF YOU WANT TO.
>> Ann: (cheers)
>> Eva: I CHOOSE ANN
TO COME ALONG WITH ME,
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST NO ONE ELSE
I WOULD WANT THERE BUT ANN.
>> Yaya: IT WAS A VERY GOOD DAY.
I THINK I DID A REALLY GOOD JOB.
WHAT I DID NOT DO A GOOD JOB OF
DOING WAS GETTING THERE ON TIME.
BUT I KIND OF DID THE GIRLS
A FAVOR,
BECAUSE MY NONPRESENCE THERE
GAVE SOMEONE ELSE A CHANCE TO
WIN.
>> Yaya: IT'S COOL.
I JUST CAME BACK AND, SERIOUSLY,
WAS IN THE BATHTUB FOR, LIKE, AN
HOUR.
JUST SITTIN' THERE, LIKE--
>> Ann: BOILING YOUR FACE.
>> Yaya: SO TELL ME WHO WON.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> Amanda: EVA WON.
YAYA WAS LIKE, "NO BIG DEAL."
BUT I KNOW SHE'S WORRIED
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
IT'LL BE BROUGHT UP IN PANEL.
>> Yaya: DID THEY SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT ME?
>> Amanda: NO.
>> Eva: I'M UP AT 6:30.
I AM SO STOKED
TO GO AND MEET
WITH OUR MYSTERY GUEST.
WE PULL UP TO THIS VERY ELITE
PART OF TOWN.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO IS GONNA
BE HERE WAITING FOR US
AT BREAKFAST.
>> Toyohiko: MORNING.
>> Ann: (speaks Japanese)
>> Toyohiko: MY NAME IS TOYOHIKO
MIKIMOTO, THE CHAIRMAN OF
MIKIMOTO.
>> Eva: I'VE HEARD OF HIM.
ANN IS STILL IN SPACE,
LIKE, "WHO?"
BUT STILL SHE ALREADY
MADE A PLAN.
IF SHE DIDN'T KNOW
WHO THE PERSON WAS,
SHE WAS GONNA STILL ACT LIKE SHE
KNEW HIM,
WHICH IS VERY GOOD, BANANA. VERY
GOOD.
>> Toyohiko: WE HAVE A STORE
DOWNSTAIRS, SO I HAVE
SECOND SURPRISE GIFT FOR YOU.
>> Eva: (squeals)
I'M LIKE, MIKIMOTO,
THAT'S JEWELRY, LIKE, HOLD UP.
WE'RE FIXIN'
TO GET SOME JEWELRY.
WE'RE GETTIN' SOME JEWELRY.
>> Ann: WE'RE LIKE, AH!
>> Eva: THIS IS AMAZING.
>> Ann: EVA, LOOK AT THESE.
>> Eva: IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> Ann: THEY'RE ALL BEAUTIFUL.
I'LL TAKE ONE OF EVERYTHING.
EVA, I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M HERE.
LIKE, I KNOW.
>> Eva: OH!
OH, THIS IS SO PRETTY.
>> Toyohiko: THIS IS HOW
WE TREAT IMPORTANT CLIENTS.
>> Eva: A CONSULTATION TABLE.
>> Ann: OH!
>> Eva: YOU LOOK LIKE
PRINCESS DIANA.
>> Ann: A GIRL.
>> Toyohiko: HERE'S ANOTHER
SURPRISE FOR YOU AND YOU.
>> Eva: MAY I OPEN IT?
>> Toyohiko: PLEASE.
>> Eva: (gasps)
LOOK!
>> Toyohiko: THAT'S YOURS.
>> Ann: THANK YOU VERY MUCH!
>> Eva: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MINE IS PINK, HOW NOBLE.
>> Ann: OH, MY GOSH,
THIS IS BEAUTIFUL.
THESE ARE SO BEAUTIFUL.
>> Eva: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Ann: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Toyohiko: YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Ann: THANK YOU.
>> Eva: THANK YOU.
>> Ann: THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL LAST ME THE REST OF MY LIFE
AND SOMETHING THAT WILL REMIND
ME
OF THIS ENTIRE EXPERIENCE FOR
THE REST OF MY LIFE.
SO I'M SO GRATEFUL
THAT SHE PICKED ME.
AND WE'RE STILL ANN AND EVA,
EVEN THOUGH WE'VE HAD SOME
"MARRIAGE PROBLEMS."
>> Eva: (screams)
YAYA, YOUR FIVE THINGS
ALL PUT TOGETHER--
>> Ann: DON'T EQUAL THIS, HA HA!
>> Eva: LIKE,
ALL OF THEM PUT TOGETHER.
>> Ann: I KNOW!
>> Eva: HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY.
>> Ann: HELLO, SLEEPYHEADS.
>> Yaya: HOW WAS IT?
>> Ann: IT WAS AMAZING.
>> Yaya: WHAT'D YOU DO?
>> Ann: MIKIMOTO, WE GOT PEARLS.
>> Amanda: MIKIMOTO?
>> Yaya: OKAY.
>> Amanda: ARE YOU JEALOUS?
>> Yaya: HMM?
>> Yaya: THAT THEY GOT PEARLS?
NO.
>> Eva: HEY, GIRLS,
WE GOT SOME TYRA MAIL.
>> Amanda: TYRA MAIL.
>> Eva: "FOR ONE OF YOU,
YOUR FUTURE AS A TOP MODEL
IS DRAWING CLOSER.
GET READY TO HANDLE LIFE
IN THE FAST LANE."
>> Ann: WE'RE DOING A SHOOT
TODAY, I GUARANTEE IT.
>> Yaya: LIKE ON THE STREET.
>> Ann: I DON'T KNOW.
>> Yaya: IN THE FAST LANE.
>> Amanda: OH.
>> Eva: OR RUNWAY.
>> Ann: OH, MY GOD,
CAN WE PLEASE DO RUNWAY?
>> Eva: RUNWAY, THE FAST LANE.
>> Ann: CAN WE?
CAN WE DO IT, YAYA?
>> Yaya: WE CAN.
>> Ann: WITH ME, IT'S BEEN,
YOU KNOW, MORE NEGATIVE THAN
POSITIVE AS FAR AS MY PICTURES.
BUT I'M ALWAYS FIRST
ON THE RUNWAY.
>> Jay: YO, WHAT'S UP?
>> Eva: OH, WE WERE
SO NOT PREPARED FOR THIS.
>> Jay: WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> Amanda: SO THE ELEVATOR DOORS
OPEN, AND THERE'S JAY
LOOKING FABULOUS.
>> Jay: YOU GUYS
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
WALK AROUND TOKYO AND ABSORB
SOME JAPANESE STREET STYLE.
SO TODAY, I'VE DESIGNED
THIS WHOLE SHOOT
AROUND A VERY POPULAR
JAPANESE STREET STYLE.
SO YOU EXCITED?
>> Jay: YOU'RE
NOT PREPARED FOR ME?
ANN, DON'T TOUCH, HONEY.
>> Ann: I KNOW HE DIDN'T MEAN IT
IN A MEAN WAY.
BUT THE SITUATION THAT I'M IN--
FEELING LIKE I'M
THE WORST PERSON HERE,
TAKING THE WORST PICTURES--
LIKE, THAT'S NOT WHAT I NEEDED
TO HEAR RIGHT BEFORE I'M GONNA
GO DO A PHOTO SHOOT.
>> Ann: SEE, I JUST FEEL LIKE
EVERYONE THINKS I TAKE,
LIKE, AWFUL PICTURES.
WHEN I FIRST GOT
TO THE PHOTO SHOOT,
I HAD WALKED IN AND JAY SAID
SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT
OF YOU'RE LUCKY
YOU GOT A PICTURE LAST WEEK.
AND I TOOK IT AS, LIKE,
WELL, YOU KIND OF DON'T
DESERVE TO BE HERE.
I WAS HURT BY IT.
>> Danilo: MAY I SAY BLUE?
>> Mathu: BLUE HOO.
>> Eva: CAN I ASK YOU
A QUESTION?
IS THE SHOOT HERE?
>> Mathu: YOU CAN'T ASK
THAT QUESTION.
>> Eva: I UNDERSTAND.
>> Ann: IT'S THE FAST LANE.
IT'S ON THE STREET.
>> Mathu: IT COULD BE
AT A SUPERMARKET.
>> Eva: WHERE ARE WE GOING?
WE DON'T KNOW.
HOW ARE WE GETTIN' THERE?
THAT'S NOT A MOTOR HOME, IS IT?
>> Yaya: IS THAT OURS?
YAY!
>> Ann: THAT'S SO COOL.
>> Eva: THIS IS SO COOL.
>> Amanda: WHEN WE PULL UP
IN OUR LITTLE WINNIE,
WE SEE MR. JAY AND MISS J.
STANDING IN FRONT
OF THIS AWESOME BACKGROUND
OF JUST LIGHTS
ALL DOWN THE STREET.
>> Jay: YOU OBVIOUSLY CAN TELL
YOU GUYS ARE DRESSED UP
LIKE HARAJUKU JAPANIME GIRLS.
THIS IS REALLY
HOW THE GIRLS DRESS
WALKING IN THE STREETS.
WE HAVE PAGSTA MOTORCYCLES HERE.
SO YOU GIRLS
ARE GONNA BE ON BIKES,
BUT YOU GOTTA LOOK
LIKE YOU'RE IN MOTION.
THERE ARE FOUR OF YOU LEFT.
>> J.: SO IT'S--
>> Jay: THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
>> J.: 'CAUSE THE THING IS
I BEEN ON YOUR BUTT, ANN.
I HAVE A HABIT OF THROWING YOU
A KITCHEN SINK, AND YOU NEVER
THROW ME BACK A BATHTUB.
YOU THROW ME BACK,
LIKE, BATH WATER--SPLASH, OOH!
AND I NEED SOME FIERCE--
I MEAN, IT'S DOWN TO THE WIRE.
>> Ann: J. ALEXANDER, LIKE,
POINTED OUT TO ME,
"OH, WELL, YOU KNOW,
I'VE BEEN ON YOU.
AND I GIVE YOU A SINK, AND"--
WHATEVER THE ANALOGY HE USED,
IF YOU'RE GONNA DO A CRITIQUE
OF ONE PERSON,
DO THEM OF ALL FOUR OF US.
>> Jay: OKAY, LET ME JUST SEE
IF I LIKE THIS.
THIS WAS THE LAST PIECE.
OKAY, I'M NOT MAD AT IT.
>> J.: I LIKE IT.
>> Amanda: MY FIRST THOUGHT
WAS LIKE, "OH, LORD, I'M GONNA
HAVE TO RIDE THIS MOTORCYCLE?"
THEY'RE GONNA GET
A CRAZY PICTURE OUT OF THAT.
>> Jay: I WANT TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER FOR TODAY.
HIS NAME'S TAKASHI.
HE'S RIGHT HERE.
>> Amanda: HI.
>> Takashi: I'M TAKASHI.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
>> Jay: THIS IS AMANDA.
ALL RIGHT,
SO YOU'RE READY TO DO THIS.
>> Jay: TRY AND REMOVE YOURSELF
FROM POSING NOW.
>> Amanda: OKAY.
>> Jay: LIKE, TRY AND REALLY,
LIKE, GET INTO A FEEL.
FEEL THESE GIRLS.
THESE GIRLS JUST DON'T CARE
ABOUT ANYTHING.
YES, THAT'S GREAT.
I LOVE THAT.
GOOD, YES!
GREAT.
>> Amanda: YAY!
>> Jay: AMANDA TOTALLY PICKED UP
ON THE HARAJUKU JAPANIME GIRLS.
>> J.: NOW REMEMBER WHAT I SAID
TO YOU, MISS HONEY CABBAGE.
WE DON'T WANT EDUCATED MODELS.
WE WANT CLEVER MODELS.
I KNOW YOU'RE SMART.
LEAVE THE EDUCATION BACK THERE
FOR THIS PHOTO SHOOT, BABY.
>> Yaya: BEFORE GOING OUT THERE,
MISS J'S LIKE, "DON'T THINK.
WE DON'T WANT YOUR EDUCATION."
BEING AN INTELLIGENT
BLACK WOMAN,
OF COURSE I'M PROUD OF IT.
I MEAN, WHATEVER.
>> Yaya: I HAD ALL THESE IDEAS
I WANTED TO DO.
BUT THE PHOTOGRAPHER
WAS VERY QUICK WITH THE FINGER.
JUST CLICK, CLICK,
CLICK, CLICK, CLICK.
>> Takashi: OKAY.
>> Yaya: (sighs)
PLEASE HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
WELL, THE TYRA MAIL
DID SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
LIFE ON THE FAST LANE.
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW THAT
THAT WAS GOING TO PLAY INTO
THE MODE OF PHOTOGRAPHY.
CAN YOU HOLD ON
ONE SECOND, PLEASE?
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
>> Jay: YAYA KEEPS
GIVIN' THIS ATTITUDE.
AND SHE'S SLOWLY MAKING ME
DISLIKE HER.
>> Yaya: WHOO, WHOO, WHOO, WHOO.
>> Jay: THAT'S HOW IT IS
SOMETIMES.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
KEEP THE CHIN DOWN.
THERE YOU GO.
IF THIS IS--
IF YOU'RE THE CAMERA,
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
YOU'RE BOBBIN' UP HERE.
>> Eva: IT'S DEFINITELY REALLY
WEIRD TO WORK THE MOTORCYCLE,
BECAUSE ONCE YOU GET ON IT
TO FIND YOUR ANGLE--
WHAT MAKES YOU LOOK LONGER,
STRONGER, TALLER, FIERCER--
IT'S KIND OF DIFFICULT
TRYING TO KEEP IT ALTOGETHER.
OH, I LOST MY SHOE.
I'M FLYIN'.
I'M ROLLIN' DOWN THE STREET,
HONEY.
>> Jay: NOT SO COY ON THE BIKE,
A LITTLE MORE GRR.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU'RE JUST PULLING IT BACK.
BRING IT OUT NOW.
NOW'S THE TIME TO BRING IT.
MORE GRR.
A LITTLE MORE--COME ON.
A LITTLE MORE EVA.
I KNOW YOU CAN DO IT.
EVA TRIES HARD,
AND I LOVE EVA'S PERSONALITY.
BUT THEN TODAY, AGAIN,
SHE FELL FLAT.
YOU'RE A COSMOPOLITAN MODEL NOW.
YOU'VE TRAVELED THE WORLD.
GIVE IT TO ME.
>> Ann: GIVE IT TO YOU.
>> Jay: CAN YOU DO THAT?
THANK YOU.
>> Ann: I CAN TRY, JAY.
>> Jay: DON'T LOSE THE ENERGY.
PICK IT UP.
IT'S GETTIN' DEAD.
WHERE'S YOUR EYE LINE?
CAMERA'S DOWN HERE.
DOWN HERE.
>> Takashi: LOOK AT ME.
YEAH.
>> Ann: WHAT?
>> Jay: WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I FEEL LIKE WE'RE ON THE STREETS
HERE IN TOKYO
YOU GOT THIS AMAZING BACKGROUND,
THIS BIKE.
YOU LOOK INCREDIBLE.
YOU'RE DOWN TO THE FINAL FOUR.
>> Ann: I KNOW THAT,
BUT IT'S LIKE I FEEL LIKE
I DON'T EVEN DESERVE TO BE HERE.
AND I FEEL LIKE EVERY TIME
SOMEONE SAYS SOMETHING,
IT MAKES IT THAT MUCH WORSE.
I DO.
>> Jay: IS THERE ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS ENVIRONMENT
AND THE WAY YOU LOOK
THAT REMINDS YOU
OF ANY KIND OF REFERENCE?
DID YOU AT LEAST
SEE "THE MATRIX"?
EVERY TIME I COME UP
WITH A VISUAL REFERENCE FOR ANN,
WHETHER IT'S "MY FAIR LADY,"
"THE MATRIX,"
SHE JUST DOESN'T GET IT.
YOU LOOK LIKE A FLIGHT ATTENDANT
GONE WRONG.
WORK IT, COME ON.
THERE YOU GO.
I LIKE THAT INTENSITY.
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE PISSED.
HOLD IT.
YOU HATE ME!
LET'S GO!
THERE YOU GO.
SHE HATES ME.
ALL RIGHT, ANN, WHAT'S UP?
>> Ann: I DON'T HATE YOU, JAY.
I LOVE YOU.
>> Jay: ANN CANNOT RELY
ON SOMEBODY PROVOKING HER
CONSTANTLY ON SET
TO GET A GOOD PHOTOGRAPH.
>> Ann: I SUCK.
>> Jay: WELL,
YOU MADE IT THIS FAR.
>> Ann: I FEEL LIKE EVERYONE'S
KIND OF LIKE, "OH, WHATEVER."
YOU KNOW, THEY WANNA HELP ME,
BUT THEY'RE JUST,
LIKE, ARE GIVING UP HOPE.
AND I FEEL LIKE I AM, TOO.
>> Tyra: HELLO.
>> Amanda: HI, TYRA.
YAYA AND I ARE JUST CHILLIN'
IN OUR ROOM,
AND IN WALKS MISS BANKS.
>> Tyra: WHEN I USED TO TRAVEL
ALL ACROSS THE WORLD, I WOULD
GET REALLY, REALLY HOMESICK.
AND MY MOM STARTED TRAVELING
WITH ME.
AND MY MAMA'S HERE TODAY.
>> All: OH!
>> Tyra: COME DOWN.
HERE'S MY MAMA.
>> Amanda: OH, WOW.
>> Yaya: NICE TO MEET YOU.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S
SOMETHING ABOUT A MOMMY
THAT JUST MAKES YOU FEEL LIKE,
"OH, EVERYTHING'S OKAY."
>> Tyra: SO TODAY,
INSTEAD OF A ONE-ON-ONE,
WE'RE GONNA DO A TWO-ON-ONE.
>> All: OH!
>> Tyra: AND, AMANDA,
YOU'RE GONNA BE FIRST.
>> Amanda: OKAY.
>> Carolyn: HI, AMANDA.
>> Tyra: SO HOW YOU FEELING
SO FAR?
>> Amanda: NOW I JUST FEEL SAD.
I BOUGHT THIS KIMONO,
AND I BOUGHT THIS NECKLACE.
>> Tyra: WHY DO YOU FEEL SAD?
>> Amanda: BECAUSE MY FAMILY
NEEDS MONEY.
>> Carolyn: WE, AS WOMEN,
WE WANT TO DO EVERYTHING
FOR EVERYONE.
>> Tyra: ESPECIALLY THIS ONE.
>> Carolyn: AND WE ALWAYS
PLACE OURSELVES LAST.
YOU CAN'T HELP EVERYONE ELSE
TILL YOU HELP YOURSELF FIRST.
>> Tyra: SO WHAT'S UP, YAYA?
>> Yaya: IT'S--THIS IS
REALLY KIND OF A STRESSFUL TIME,
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A HARD BALANCE
OF JUST MAKING SURE THAT--
OH, THAT I'M SEEN FOR WHO I AM.
ESPECIALLY WANTING
TO BE A MODEL,
IT'S EASY TO GET LOOKED OVER.
LIKE, OH, SHE'S JUST
A PRETTY GIRL, LIKE, YOU KNOW.
BUT YEAH, BUT I ALSO
WRITE REALLY WELL, AND I ALSO
DO ALL THESE OTHER THINGS AND--
>> Carolyn: YOU DON'T HAVE
TO ADVERTISE YOUR INTELLIGENCE.
IT SHINES ON ITS OWN.
>> Yaya: I UNDERSTAND
COMPLETELY.
>> Tyra: FROM STARTING BEING
THE NEGATIVE KIND OF GIRL...
>> Eva: AND I DON'T WANT TO HURT
ANYONE'S FEELINGS,
BUT I THINK IT HURTS ME, TOO.
>> Tyra: I THINK YOU DO.
>> Eva: I--
>> Tyra: YOU DO WANT TO HURT
PEOPLE'S FEELINGS.
>> Eva: I DON'T.
>> Tyra: YOU'RE A SMART GIRL,
EVA, AND YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
WHERE DO YOU THINK YOU ARE NOW
IN TERMS OF THAT?
>> Eva: A LOT OF TIMES I FEEL
MISUNDERSTOOD.
ANYTHING I SAY, AND THE
INTENSIONS OF IT
GOES COMPLETELY SIDEWAYS.
>> Carolyn: THE HARDEST THING
FOR, I THINK, MOST HUMAN BEINGS
IS TO LOOK INWARD.
>> Eva: UM, LIKE, I BEEN THROUGH
A WHOLE LOT PERSONALLY.
AND I'VE BEEN, LIKE,
AT THE BOTTOM, AT THE TOP,
LIKE, EMOTIONALLY.
AND I GUESS FOR ME
IT'S ALWAYS A STRUGGLE
CONSTANTLY TRYING TO REBUILD
MYSELF AND TO TRY
TO BECOME A BETTER PERSON.
I JUST GOTTA KIND OF REMEMBER
TO BRING MYSELF UP BUT TRY
NOT TO TEAR OTHER PEOPLE DOWN
AT THE SAME TIME.
>> Tyra: KIND OF LIKE
CHECKING YOURSELF BEFORE,
LIKE, YOU'RE LIKE
EVA'S NOT FEELING THAT GREAT
ABOUT HERSELF RIGHT NOW.
SO SHE WANTS TO THROW A DAGGER.
PULL IT BACK,
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> Carolyn: AND THAT'S
LOOKING AT YOURSELF.
>> Tyra: YEAH.
>> Carolyn: FOCUSING ON
YOURSELF.
>> Tyra: LET'S TALK ABOUT YOU AS
A MODEL.
>> Ann: I BROKE DOWN YESTERDAY.
>> Tyra: ABOUT WHAT?
>> Ann: PEOPLE TALKING
ABOUT HOW, LIKE,
I SHOULD HAVE GONE HOME
AND, LIKE, LAST WEEK.
AND IT HURT SO, SO BAD
TO HEAR THEM SAY THAT.
LIKE, I WAS LIKE,
"DO I NOT BELONG HERE?"
>> Carolyn: YOU'RE GOING
INTO AN INDUSTRY
THAT THAT'S ALL THEY DO.
AND THEY'LL TELL YOU TO YOUR
FACE THAT YOU'RE NOT RIGHT FOR
THE JOB.
YOU GOTTA GET A THICK SKIN.
>> Tyra: YOU ARE STILL HERE,
AND SO IT'S UP TO YOU TO--
>> Ann: WORK IT.
>> Tyra: YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Ann: THANK YOU.
>> Tyra: HELLO.
MY BROTHER WAS STATIONED IN
OKINAWA FOR ABOUT EIGHT YEARS.
SO I WOULD COME HERE OFTEN
JUST TO BE WITH MY BROTHER
AND HIS WIFE.
MY BROTHER IS SINCE DIVORCED,
BUT MY JAPANESE FAMILY IS HERE.
>> All: AW.
>> Eva: GOING TO DINNER
WITH TYRA AND MEET THE REST
OF HER JAPANESE FAMILY.
>> Tyra: CINDY, WHAT'S YOUR
FAVORITE AMERICAN FOOD?
>> Tyra: I KNOW YOU DON'T LIKE
MUSHROOMS.
>> Amanda: IT'S GOOD
TO HAVE FAMILY AROUND,
EVEN IF IT'S NOT YOUR OWN.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
THE COMPETITION IS GETTING
HARDER AND MORE INTENSE.
>> Ann: AND EVERY WEEK
WE NEVER KNOW WHO'S GOING HOME.
IT'S LIKE--YOU'RE LIKE
NONE OF US WILL GO HOME.
>> Eva: NEVER, NO.
>> Tyra: CRAZY, RIGHT?
IT'S INSANE.
>> Amanda: WE'RE WALKING IN
FROM DINNER, AND THERE'S
A TYRA MAIL ON THE TABLE.
"TOMORROW
YOU WILL MEET THE JUDGES.
ONLY THREE OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
THE FURTHER WE GO,
THE MORE SURREAL IT GETS.
AND JUST THINKING THAT I'M GONNA
BE TOP THREE,
IT'S LUDICROUS.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY LUDICROUS.
>> Yaya: AT THIS POINT,
ALL FOUR OF US HAVE IT
OR CAN GET IT,
SO IT'S A VERY INTIMIDATING
PLACE TO BE.
>> Ann: LIKE, WHY DO I FEEL
LIKE I DON'T DESERVE TO BE HERE?
BECAUSE THEY PICK APART EVERY
LITTLE THING THAT I DO.
LIKE, WHATEVER.
>> Eva: ANN, HONEY CHILD,
I HOPE YOU GOT A GOOD PICTURE
IN THERE SOMEWHERE, BECAUSE I
DO NOT WANNA SEE YOU GO.
>> Tyra: WELCOME BACK TO THE
JUDGING ROOM.
TODAY, WE ARE GOING TO BE MAKING
OUR 11th CUT.
AND THIS CUT WILL BRING US ONE
STEP CLOSER TOWARDS DETERMINING
WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW, OF COURSE, YOU ALL KNOW
WE HAVE SOME FABULOUS PRIZES--
A CONTRACT WITH THE TOP
INTERNATIONAL MODELING AGENCY
FORD MODELS,
A FASHION SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
WE HAVE SOME VERY GLAMOROUS
JUDGES.
FIRST, WE HAVE
MISS JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S FIRST
SUPERMODELS.
>> Janice: BUT YOU KNEW THAT.
>> Tyra: NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLé MARIN, A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
WE HAVE A DYNAMIC DUO
OF GUEST JUDGES THIS WEEK,
SHINGO AND HITOMI.
YOU'LL BE EVALUATED ON YOUR
PHOTO FROM THE ANIME SHOOT
AND ON THE TEST,
WHICH SHINGO AND HITOMI
WILL BE ADMINISTERING.
>> Shingo: THIS WEEK YOU LEARNED
ABOUT EXTREME STREET FASHION.
AND YOU HAVE 15 MINUTES
TO CHANGE AND COME BACK
AND SHOW US YOUR OWN PERSONAL
STREET STYLE.
READY.
GO.
>> Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
SO FIRST, YAYA.
STEP FORWARD.
>> Nolé: FROM THE WAIST DOWN,
NOT A BIG FAN.
>> Tyra: I LIKE YOUR LOOK.
I THINK IT'S ONE OF THOSE COOL,
I DON'T REALLY CARE, BUT REALLY,
YOU'RE, LIKE, SERVIN' IT.
>> Shingo: I THINK YOU LOOK
GREAT, BUT WE WEREN'T ABLE
TO SEE YOU AT THE GO-SEE.
SO--
>> Janice: WHAT HAPPENED?
>> Shingo: SHE WAS LATE.
>> Janice: YOU CANNOT BE LATE
IN JAPAN OR NEW YORK OR PARIS.
>> Yaya: I LOOKED AT THE MAP
AND MISUNDERSTOOD IT AND I--
>> Janice: YAWN, YAWN,
YAWN, YAWN.
>> Tyra: SO, YAYA,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO SIMULATE
RIDING ON A MOTORCYCLE,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> Nolé: OH, WOW.
>> Tyra: WHOA.
>> Janice: THIS IS SOME
OF THE BEST HAIR AND MAKEUP
I HAVE EVER SEEN.
JAPANESE VOGUE.
>> Nigel: YOU HAVE QUITE A
MUSCULAR BODY.
YOUR ARMS LOOK VERY BIG.
AND YOUR LEG LOOKS A LITTLE
CHUNKY, TOO.
>> Tyra: I THINK IF YOU WOULD
HAVE SAT MORE FORWARD,
LEANED FORWARD AND PUT YOUR LEGS
DOWN ON THE SIDE,
YOU WOULD HAVE CREATED MORE OF
AN OPTICAL ILLUSION OF LENGTH.
>> Janice: HAIR AND MAKEUP--TEN,
BODY POSE--MM, TWO.
>> Tyra: ALL RIGHT, AMANDA.
YOU'RE NEXT.
>> Hitomi: I DON'T LIKE IT.
YOUR STOCKINGS--
>> Tyra: SOCKS.
>> Janice: PULL THEM DOWN.
>> Hitomi: BLACK BELT BETTER.
>> Janice: BLACK BELT BETTER,
SO JUST TAKE THE BELT OFF.
TAKE THE PINK
AND THE YELLOW OFF.
>> Tyra: AMANDA, YOUR LEGS LOOK
SO HIP AND SEXY AND CUTE.
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> Janice: OH!
THAT'S GORGEOUS.
>> Nigel: YOU LOOK LIKE
THE PERFECT BARBIE ANIME DOLL.
>> Tyra: SELLING MOTORCYCLES,
BUT YOU'RE LIKE,
"I'M FINE, TOO."
>> Nigel: THE ONLY PROBLEM
I WOULD SAY IS IT LOOKS LIKE
YOUR HAND IS COMING OUT
OF THE MIDDLE OF YOUR WAIST.
>> Tyra: YEAH,
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT.
NEXT IS ANN.
>> Janice: THE SKIRT'S
KILLIN' ME.
I CAN'T STAND THE SKIRT.
TAKE OFF THE SOCKS, PLEASE,
AND LOSE THE BAG.
>> Nigel: WHAT ON EARTH'S
GOING ON?
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU'RE
FAST ASLEEP, LIKE YOU'RE BORED.
>> Ann: NO,
IT'S JUST, LIKE, ME TAKING IN
WHAT YOU GUYS WERE SAYING.
>> Nolé: LET ME SEE HAPPY.
LET ME SEE SAD.
LET ME SEE SEXY.
YOU HAVEN'T CHANGED AT ALL.
>> Nigel: AND I KNOW IT'S A LOT
OF CRITICISMS, A LOT
OF HARSH THINGS, BUT YOU CAN BE
A LITTLE BIT MORE ALERT.
JUST BE ON TOP OF IT.
>> Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
THERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> Janice: I LOVE YOUR POSE.
BUT THE HAIR AND MAKEUP
IS WEARING YOU.
YOU'RE KIND OF NOT WEARING
THE HAIR AND MAKEUP.
>> Nigel: ANN, AT THIS STAGE,
THIS PHOTOGRAPH
IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
>> Janice: HOW'D YOU FEEL
WHEN YOU WERE
BEING PHOTOGRAPHED, ANN?
FIND ME AN EMOTION.
>> Ann: FOR ME, IT WAS LIKE
EXCITING TO BE ON THE BIKE
AND BE SOMETHING THAT, LIKE--
>> Janice: I KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
BUT WE DON'T SEE WHAT YOU MEAN
OR HOW YOU'RE FEELING,
BECAUSE YOU'RE--THERE'S
NO ENERGY COMING FROM WITHIN.
>> Tyra: WHO'S
YOUR FAVORITE ACTRESS?
>> Ann: I DON'T REALLY HAVE ONE.
>> Tyra: WHO'S
YOUR FAVORITE SINGER?
>> Ann: I JUST LISTEN
TO ALL TYPES--I DON'T HAVE,
LIKE, A PARTICULAR.
>> Tyra: BUT MAYBE
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT PULLING
FROM INSPIRATION.
>> Ann: LIKE,
WE CAN'T GO TO THE LIBRARY.
WE CAN'T WATCH MOVIES.
WE CAN'T DO THIS AND--
>> Janice: OOH.
>> Nolé: FINALLY I SEE PASSION.
>> Ann: OKAY, BUT I'M LIKE--
>> Nigel: WE CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT YOU HAVEN'T
HAD REFERENCES FROM BEFORE.
>> Nolé: YOU ARE AN ATHLETE,
CORRECT?
WHAT IS YOUR PASSION?
IS THAT YOUR PASSION IN LIFE
RIGHT NOW?
>> Ann: NO, THIS IS. I WOULDN'T
HAVE WASTED YOUR TIME
IF IT WASN'T MY PASSION.
>> Hitomi: YOU SAD... BEAUTIFUL.
>> Tyra: ALL RIGHTY, THANKS.
AND LAST IS EVA.
>> Nolé: THIS IS JUST NOT
HAPPENING.
>> Tyra: I THINK IF HER PANTS
WERE SHORTER
SHE CAN WORK THE LEG WARMERS.
>> Janice: CAN WE GET SOME
SCISSORS?
LET'S JUST HACK UP THOSE SHORTS.
THERE YOU GO.
>> Tyra: YEAH.
>> Nolé: OH, LOOK AT THAT.
>> Janice: THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE.
>> Tyra: SO YOU HAD A PHOTO
SHOOT FOR JAPANESE ANIME.
>> Nolé: WHAT HAPPENED?
>> Janice: CLEARLY THIS IS JUST
A BEAUTY SHOT FOR YOU.
YOUR POSE IS NOT WORKING AT ALL.
>> Nigel: EVA,
EVEN AS A HEADSHOT, I DON'T
THINK THIS PICTURE WORKS.
>> Shingo: YEAH, ME EITHER.
>> Nigel: I'VE SEEN YOU WITH
A LOT MORE LIFE IN YOUR EYES.
>> Janice: WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE MODEL IN EVA DIVA?
WHERE'D SHE GO?
>> Eva: SHE DIDN'T GO ANYWHERE.
ACTUALLY, I GUESS SHE DIDN'T
PERFORM AS GOOD AS SHE THOUGHT.
>> Tyra: SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND THEN WE'LL CALL YOU BACK,
AND I'LL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE
OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED.
>> Ann: ONCE WE GO THROUGH PANEL
AND THEY'RE DELIBERATING,
I'M THINKING
THAT THERE'S NO CHANCE IN HELL
THAT I'M STAYING.
OKAY, WHO'S
YOUR FAVORITE ACTRESS?
WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE MODEL?
WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE THIS?
WHO'S YOUR FAVORITE BAND?
OKAY, LIKE WHAT, MOTLEY CRUE?
LIKE, DO YOU WANT ME TO JUST
RATTLE OFF THINGS BECAUSE--
>> Amanda: YES.
>> Ann: HALF THE TIME THAT'S NOT
EVEN REAL.
PEOPLE SAY IT
AND THEY DON'T REALLY MEAN IT.
>> Yaya: SO WHAT?
>> Ann: WHY AM I?
BECAUSE I'M VOCAL ABOUT IT
AND HONEST ABOUT IT AND I DON'T
TRY AND LIE LIKE YOU DO,
BECAUSE YOU DO.
>> Eva: HOW DO I LIE ABOUT--
>> Ann: ABOUT KNOWING--LIKE,
PRETENDING YOU KNOW ABOUT--
>> Eva: WHAT I KNOW
AND WHO I KNOW I SAY.
I'VE NEVER SAID ANYONE
I DON'T KNOW.
I FEEL LIKE I'M A SINCERE
PERSON.
I FEEL LIKE WHAT I SAY IS WHAT I
MEAN.
I DON'T SAY ANYTHING
FOR THE HELL OF IT.
DON'T TRY TO PLAY ME
LIKE I'VE BEEN LYING,
LIKE, "OH, I KNOW FASHION.
I KNOW THIS.
I KNOW THAT.
NO, I DON'T. NO, I DON'T.
>> Ann: EVA, STOP YELLING.
WE'RE NOT HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION NOW, BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITHOUT BEING DEFENSIVE.
>> Eva: I'M SAYING, BUT DON'T
TALK TO THE OTHER PEOPLE
AND SAY THAT I'VE BEEN LYING IF
I HAVEN'T.
>> Ann: SHH. WE'RE NOT HAVING A
CONVERSATION.
I WAS JUST KIND OF LIKE,
WHATEVER.
>> Eva: I'VE PRAYED FOR ANN SO
MUCH.
WE'RE BOTH IN COMPETITION, BUT I
PRAYED FOR THAT GIRL SO MUCH.
OUTSIDE OF WHAT
EVERYTHING ELSE YOU SEE IN US,
I SAW GOOD IN HER.
SO I WAS LIKE, "I HOPE SHE DOES
WELL, AND IF I DON'T WIN,
AT LEAST I KNOW
A GOOD PERSON DID WIN."
>> Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF THESE FOUR GIRLS
SHOULD GO HOME.
YAYA.
>> Nolé: I ACTUALLY LOVE THIS
PHOTO.
I THINK HER FACE
IS ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
>> Shingo: I DIDN'T REALLY LIKE
HER POSING.
>> Nigel: IT KIND OF LOOKS LIKE
A SORT OF PURPLE BUMBLE BEE
ON THIS MOTORCYCLE.
>> Janice: BUT ISN'T THAT
WHAT TOKYO FASHION'S ALL ABOUT?
>> Nigel: PERHAPS,
BUT SHE DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE A MODEL TO ME HERE.
>> Tyra: AMANDA.
>> Janice: AMANDA
REEKS OF A MODEL.
>> Nigel: IN PERSON,
SHE DOES NOT LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
AND I DON'T THINK
SHE NECESSARILY HAS IT.
>> Janice: I THINK YOU'RE WRONG.
>> Tyra: ANN.
>> Nolé: WE'RE COMING SO CLOSE
TO THE END, AND ANN STILL
HAS NOT MASTERED THE CAMERA.
>> Tyra: ANN
IS THE DEFINITION OF A GIRL
THAT JUST THINKS MODELING
IS JUST ABOUT BEING PRETTY
AND GETTIN' YOUR MAKEUP DONE.
I DON'T THINK SHE THINKS
IT'S ABOUT HARD WORK.
IT HAS ANYTHING TO DO
WITH ANY TYPE OF RESEARCH.
>> Janice: WE'VE GIVEN HER
THIS SHORT TIME
TO TAKE IN THE KNOWLEDGE,
AND THERE HASN'T BEEN
ANY GROWTH.
>> Tyra: EVA.
>> Nolé: EVA HAS DONE
MUCH BETTER IN OTHER SHOOTS.
>> Hitomi: I THINK BEST PHOTO.
>> Nigel: TO ME, WHAT REALLY
MAKES ME WANT TO SEE EVA IN
WEEK AFTER WEEK IS THE FACT THAT
SHE HAS A LOVELY PERSONALITY.
>> Tyra: I DON'T SEE A MODEL
AT ALL IN THIS PHOTO.
BUT I DO SEE A MODEL
IN FRONT OF US
WHEN SHE'S DRESSED PERFECTLY.
BUT I FEEL LIKE A MODEL
SHOULD ALWAYS LOOK LIKE A MODEL
NO MATTER WHAT THE HELL SHE HAS
ON.
>> Nolé: ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tyra: PAPER BAG SACK AND SHE
SHOULD STILL LOOK LIKE A MODEL.
>> Tyra: I HAVE FOUR YOUNG
LADIES STANDING IN FRONT OF ME.
BUT I ONLY HAVE THREE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE THREE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL STILL BE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND OUT OF YOU FOUR,
THE JUDGES CAN FIND
NOT ONE OF YOU
THAT THEY THINK COULD BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
IT IS UP TO YOU TO STEP UP,
BECAUSE AFTER TONIGHT,
THERE IS ONLY ONE WEEK LEFT.
ONE WEEK FOR YOU TO PROVE
TO THESE PEOPLE BEHIND ME
AND TO ME
THAT YOU CAN DO THIS.
THE FIRST NAME THAT I'M GOING TO
CALL...
>> Tyra: AMANDA.
AMANDA, I'M NOT GONNA CRITIQUE
YOU TONIGHT.
I WANT YOU TO CRITIQUE YOURSELF.
>> Amanda: UM, I THINK
I NEED TO WORK ON MY PRESENCE
IN PERSON.
>> Tyra: YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M GOING TO
CALL--
YAYA.
>> Yaya: I KNOW THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR A TOP MODEL
TO BE LIKABLE BY EVERYBODY.
>> Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS, YAYA.
>> Yaya: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Tyra: WILL ANN AND EVA PLEASE
STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY
HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS STILL
IN THE RUNNING TO BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
AND THE GIRL THAT I DON'T CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO HER HOMESTAY HERE IN TOKYO,
PACK HER BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
WITH YOU, EVA,
I FEEL LIKE ANYTHING NEGATIVE
THAT WE TALK ABOUT
THAT COMES FROM YOU
IS CONSTANTLY BLAMED
ON OTHER PEOPLE
RATHER THAN LOOKING
ON THE INSIDE.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO LOOK ON THE INSIDE.
MY MAMA WAS HERE
AND TALKED TO YOU ABOUT THAT.
AND, ANN, TO BE IN THIS
COMPETITION, YOU HAD TIME
FROM THAT PHONE CALL THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE A SEMIFINALIST
TO RIGHT NOW,
AND I FEEL LIKE YOU
ARE NOT TAKING RESPONSIBILITY
FOR YOU.
YOU WERE THE CAPTAIN
OF THAT WATER POLO TEAM
BECAUSE YOU WANTED IT,
BECAUSE YOU STUDIED IT.
BUT YOU STILL HAD TO KNOW
HOW TO TREAD WATER
BEFORE YOU MADE THAT TEAM.
AND THAT'S WHY
EVA'S STILL IN THE RUNNING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> Amanda: I'LL SEE YOU LATER,
BABY.
>> Eva: BYE, 'NANA.
>> Ann: COMING INTO THIS,
I THOUGHT EVA,
YOU KNOW, THE BEST FRIEND I MADE
OUT OF THIS WHOLE SITUATION.
BUT IT'S BEEN
TENSION BETWEEN US.
I THINK SHE WILL BE SAD
THAT I DIDN'T HUG HER.
BUT IF SHE LETS THAT AFFECT
OUR FRIENDSHIP, THEN IT WAS
NEVER MEANT TO BE FRIENDSHIP
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
AND I'M SICK AND TIRED OF, LIKE,
GETTING IN FRONT OF PANEL.
I'M JUST LIKE,
TONIGHT WAS HORRIBLE.
LIKE, THAT WAS THE WORST THING,
LIKE, AND EVEN JUST
WITH THE WEEK I HAD, IT WAS--
IT WAS REALLY HARD
TO, LIKE, SIT THERE AND TAKE IT.
AND THAT'S IT.
I'M DONE.
I CAN'T CRY.
>> Tyra: HERE'S WHAT'S COMING
UP ON THE SEASON FINALE OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
AFTER 11 DIFFICULT CUTS,
ONLY EVA, AMANDA
AND YAYA REMAIN.
A MAJOR COVER GIRL CONTRACT
IS ON THE LINE
AS THE FINALISTS
STRUT THEIR STUFF
IN A CUTTING-EDGE
TOKYO FASHION SHOW...
>> Janice: YEAH!
>> Tyra: AND THE JUDGES
STRUGGLE WITH THEIR TOUGHEST
DECISION YET.
WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
I'M SHAKING, YOU GUYS.
>> Nolé: (sighs)